so hi there I'm curious in the audience
who here is excited about animation whoo
my faithful I'm so happy okay how many
of you use CSS animations how many of
you use a javascript animation library
like gee sap okay fewer if your hands
it's okay we're here to talk about
bridging those two today and so Before
we jump in and what I do i help clients
with motion design systems and animating
their user interfaces I worked with
Salesforce on their motion design system
portion of the lighting design system
but back in the day I used to be a
cartoonist and this is how I started my
long path to where I am now I used to be
a professional cartoonist I had I drew
comics had many fans all over the world
this was my goodness like a decade ago
and then one day I needed to get some
surgery and cartoonists in the United
States of America do not make enough to
get surgery so I had to go find a real
job and I ended up making comics for a
living I ended up I ended up moving into
web development I put my web skills to
use turning my back on creativity and I
thought I will never tell stories again
i am a i'm a web developer now i am a
front-end developer everything is CSS
everything is typography nothing moves
not even room for illustrations it's
over I thought so few years passed and I
remembered all of a sudden Scott McCloud
this guy he is the who has read making
comics understanding comics reinventing
comics if you haven't read it it's a
great book by scott mccloud he is the
godfather of the future of comics and he
wrote a really beautiful book called
reinventing comics which was all about
the infinite canvas and what you know
was saying earlier really spoke to me
about arcing the web for it because i
was looking at all these AP is that were
coming out for speech recognition and
audio generation and
animation and I was thinking oh my
goodness it's what Scott MacLeod said
there is an infinite canvas in my
browser and I can realize stories I
don't need flash I can use JavaScript
and CSS we can do this yes yes so I quit
my job and I keep falling in love with
the wrong jobs uh so I quit my job and I
gave myself fully to it I started
traveling and making cool things and
speaking and you know coming to places
like Argentina thank you so much for
having me it's so good to be here I've
never been to South American continent
so it's like wow it's huge located well
here Wow very exciting great steak so
yes my first project was Alice in video
land and I do not mean the Swedish
electroclash rock band although I'm a
big fan of theirs Alison video land was
a project I did with adobe's inspire
magazine to showcase some ways that you
could use CSS animation to tell stories
that until this time had been largely
the domain of flash which everyone was
morning and couldn't use I still get
emails from designers because more
designers and web developers saw this I
still get emails from designers saying I
saw that it really inspired me to get
into using code and front-end
development to tell new and unusual
stories in different ways that's pretty
powerful it's exciting reminds me a lot
of the emails I used to get from young
women who read my comics online so that
was a video that I showed you I could
use After Effects to just record that
and show it to you there wasn't a whole
lot of interaction happening there's a
lot of animation but not a lot of
interaction CSS animations are really
declarative they're not very interactive
if you want to do interactive animations
you need a library like G sap or snap
SVG or another kind of JavaScript thing
a mochis we don't have a lot of
interactive animation libraries but we
have some good standards and solid
standards it's still tough though
because browsers let's face it browsers
were designed for scrolling animation
used to be the only the only realm of
was in flash the only thing that
browsers could animate was the page
scrolling so when CSS animations and
transitions came out of course browsers
are like oh no this isn't very
performant oh when is that thing start
moving around ah they went a little
crazy it's not it's not a game engine
it's a it's a document reader it's a
text document reader and now it's got to
make things move and everything is about
to change so before CSS animations and
transitions over a decade ago there was
this thing called synchronized
multimedia integration language that's a
lot but we know it as smile pronounced
like the smile it's it's used to animate
SVG's and this was one of the first
animation ap is that was written it was
created via that slow process we know as
standards committees so in 2009 oh my
goodness like a decade later safaris
developers were working on trying to
make the iOS safari experience feel and
look as good as native web apps you know
people are browsing the apple site on
their iPhone shouldn't it look as cool
as all the apps they're using on their
iPhone so without the standards process
they sort of introduced two new specs of
their own because the standards
committees had been chasing each other
in a circle going how do we make
animations no one could agree on
anything it wasn't getting done so
safaris team just came in and said boom
you have them now when Internet Explorer
saw this they were like you want us to
implement all these different animation
engines smile and CSS animations and
transitions and each these are 33
animation engines each one of them with
a slightly different interpretation all
the browsers are interpreting these in
different ways this is this is getting
way too difficult tell you what we will
implement these all of these animations
if you w3c can give us one API that will
dictate how each of them should behave
the one API to
rule them all if you will an API that
could underlie all of the current
animation specifications and any future
ones that would come along one that
would bring animation to the browser and
let the browser animate more than just
scrolling and this would also of course
open up this rendering engine to
JavaScript developers so they could form
their own animations in the future it
was a really big API it took a long time
to write and after several years of
drafting spec authors finally are
nailing down the edge cases and even
edge has moved to adopt it we call it
the web animations API unfortunately in
the interim smile died at chrome
deprecated smile and so Internet
Explorer's like oh edge doesn't have to
implement smile wow how they dodged that
bullet well done way of saying mmm come
back to me on Friday and then the
problem just disappears so you can
already see this API at work in browser
animation in browser dev tools for
instance these are the Firefox dev tools
you can use them you see these timelines
you can scrub that is possible because
of the web animations API before the API
doing this each browser would have had
to write their own very weird code to do
this now they all can use the web
animations API to make timelines tools
that you can scrub etc so it really does
open up the engine not only for the
browsers but for individual developers
like you and I so it's an awesome it's
an awesome API the web animations API is
totally a big deal I believe in it it's
going to change how we do animation on
the web and I wanted to get the word out
so I teamed up with the Mozilla
developer network to get a grant so that
I could document it because it is such a
big API so I was like we got to document
this let's do it and who better to help
bring this API to developers and
designers everywhere then our good old
friend Alice the modern Alice in
Wonderland so with that we would like to
welcome you
to jump down the rabbit hole to web
animations API land so let's get start
with these core concepts the web
animations API is based on two models
it's got a timing model and it's got an
animation model or as I like to think of
it as the when and the what one handles
when things are happening the other
handles what things should be happening
now the web animations API is time-based
all the animations must have durations
currently these durations create
timelines let's talk a little bit about
the Cheshire Cat now let's say the
Cheshire Cat takes eight seconds to
disappear to go from being there to
being not all there we go from zero at
their 28 when he's not all there now the
web animation API takes these two values
makes a timeline and it's create
snapshots of how he should look all the
way down to milliseconds so any
particular time the browser knows what
he should look like here or here that's
very performant because it means it's
inherently see keable and searchable
it's not procedural the browser can jump
to any point in this timeline without
having to expend too much energy so one
of the ways i like to think about this
even in the spec it says it states this
that the time may be shifted backwards
and forwards scaled reverse paused
repeated this is the point you can you
can manipulate time with this API and
it's lets us do all kinds of wonderful
things which i'm going to show you we
call this kind of animation stainless
and unlike request animation frame rate
which is limited by how often the page
is repainted there are some benefits to
using this kind of timeline for this
kind of animation for instance you can
easily run animations at forwards or
backwards you can create inherently see
keable animations you can plunk down
animations pretty much anywhere in the
timeline so here's an example of
something you can't do with CSS
timelines have an inherent our hierarchy
and today inherit here are two
animations that on the left you can see
the CSS animations as we add cats each
cat starts at a different point so their
timelines are out of sync but over here
with the web animations API each one of
these cloned cats we make you're making
it inherent the timeline and its current
position of the parent cat this is
something we could not do with CSS alone
but we are able to tap the browser's
rendering engine and do it with this API
now timelines have children called
animations an animation connects a
single tween to the timeline what is a
tween I will explain that in a moment
but basically what happens is that this
tween from here from there to not all
there right here is called a keyframe
effect basically how the cat looks from
being there to just being his smile we
call that a key frame or keyframe effect
so you have a timeline and you know what
the thing should look like at any given
time but how do you make it go now the
animation allows you to play a key frame
effect along a timeline the same way a
DVD player would play a DVD so if you
can think of a DVD player as being the
animation object the key frame of flat
effect would be the DVD you put in there
keyframe effect holds all the different
ways this thing should look the way the
cat looks in the beginning all the way
to the way he looks in the end but until
you put it inside that key until you put
it inside that animation you can't play
it you can't sink it so the controls are
in animation the information for how it
should look is in the keyframe
unfortunately I don't think people even
remember this metaphor anymore let's
move along so with these two models
combined the timing and the animation
the web animation API runs all animation
engines in the browser now well now ish
it's a this is this is all on a bleeding
edge most recent Firefox and Chrome have
this stuff available from out from
underneath flags it's really exciting
so why don't I show you all how it's how
it does that with CSS animations now I'm
assuming because I saw so many hands up
that everyone here has a really good
grasp of CSS animations and transitions
by now yes okay well just in case just
in case somebody doesn't i do have a non
line course for that and there's a
special price for you because you're
awesome my goodness it's the same as the
hashtag so anyway back to what we were
talking about we got the animation
player and it takes a keyframe effect
let's take a closer look at this
keyframe effect let's make one a
keyframe of that constructor we're going
to make some CSS animations using the
web animations API I'll show you how the
browser is doing this on the back end so
in a traditional animation we get these
two things called keys your key poses
we've got tuna in point a we got to an
end point B he's the cat Gina these in
interaction development are referred to
as keyframes not keep poses because
you're not always animating animals that
would pose you're animating interfaces
so everything in between usually in
traditional animation you would pay an
intern or send us overseas where people
can work many hours for very little
money and this is why animation left
America I go to these conferences
likewise animation evening American it's
like how could you afford to make it
anyway so these are the in betweens but
in interaction development we no
in-betweens as teens you may have heard
that if you've worked with flash
speaking of anyone here ever work with
flash any all right okay I feel your
frustrations
mmm so in the API the keyframe effect
tells us what it should look like at
those key points right it basically
handles both the keep the key poses the
keys and the tweens the animation model
is the one that actually pardon the
keyframe effect handles the key poses
you can remember because it says key but
the animation model it's up to it to
decide what's going to look like in
between it's the one that figures out
those tweens it interpolates those now
this is from the original alice in
wonderland this is a CSS transition
where when you click on the bunny rabbit
he goes down the hole right and that's
done like this we've got the transition
transform takes three seconds and when
you click on him he gets a class of
interactive which changed his transform
to translate why it pops them down
that's straight forward here's the same
interaction again without CSS just using
the web animations API you can't even
tell the difference amazing right how
did I do that well the first thing you
do is you make a new keyframe effect and
in this case I went out and I got the
White Rabbit object and here's a
keyframe object that I'm passing it it's
an array with two objects holding
holding key value pairs of styles and
their properties and then you pass it a
timing properties object which specifies
the duration in milliseconds and that
the film OG forwards because it is
basically a transition is an animation
with the film modes for words sweetness
and we just save that into a variable
called rabbit down keyframes now here's
what happens if you don't set that that
Phil mode
it just goes right back to the beginning
Phil modes are handy they dictate how
the animation should respond when it's
finished and before it's begun whether
or not the keyframes should have effect
before the animation is actually played
we know a lot of these options from
their CSS counterparts if this if this
just made your eyes roll back in your
head here's a refresher duration is well
instead of transition or animation
duration it's now duration delay
familiar Phil is Phil mode iterations
it's so much shorter now instead of
animation iteration count you can just
call them iterations direction of course
and my particular favorite instead of
animation timing function it's it's what
we all know it is it's easing its easing
call it what it is this is what happens
when you don't build things by committee
you end up with these crazy words so
these end delay is a new one you haven't
seen this one before it's milliseconds
to delay after an animation has ended
these are more important for sequencing
for instance I would shoot I had a good
example but it skipped my mind
iterations start when the iteration of
the animation should start of course and
there's composite iteration composite
and spacing and we're not even going to
go there today because these things
aren't implemented on any browsers yet
so let's take take a moment to play that
animation we we can do that with the
animation object we have a keyframe
object now we've got to get it into an
animation object we're going to take
this keyframe and we're going to
put it into the DVD player I mean the
animation object so how are we going to
do that take rabbit down keyframes we're
going to make a new animation we pass it
the keyframes object and we also pass it
a timeline we're going to pass it the
document timeline right now the reason
for this is that there's only one kind
of timeline right now it's your
documents timeline the API is written in
such a way that it allows for other
timelines to be created in the future
for instance imagine a timeline based on
your scrolling position
is one that people are really excited
about for parallax effects the API is
really beautifully written in that it
needs a lot of room open for future
iterations of the web animations API to
kind of blow things open so maybe future
timelines will be open-ended they don't
have to have a set ending we'll find out
so then we of course put it inside a
variable called the rabbit down and
animation now we can do some things with
these animation objects we can pause
them we can play them we can reverse
them we can finish them if we just want
to skip right to the end and here's one
that's super exciting cancel cancel is
not something we have access to with CSS
animation right now but you could use
this for instance if you're halfway like
halfway to completing an animation but
up users said they didn't want to do
that action it's a little bit different
from finish because canceling would be
an interruption all right so we're going
to play it we take the rabbit down
animation and we just call its method of
play on it we're going to put that
inside the function down he goes and
we're going to add an event listener to
that click on the rabbit and we're going
to play the down he goes function
whenever it's clicked and of course
after he's clicked we remove that event
listener because we don't need it
anymore whoo it worked wow that was a
lot of freaking work for two lines of
CSS but now you can appreciate how your
browser does it how all browsers will be
doing it in the future but there there
is some good news we do have a shortcut
I'm sure you did not come here today for
me to show you how to write really long
examples of CSS animations so i'm going
to show you the fun short way we have
this thing called the animate method
which we can call on any animatable
object on the page don't don't try to
call it on a head element that's not
going to work but if it's an element
that can be animated you can call
animate on it so if you're a CSS
animations won't like I am you may have
noticed that the web animations API
handled this
transition more like this kind of
animation that gives you an idea of how
flexible the API is when I was first
learning how to do CSS animations
sometimes I did transitions like this in
certain cases and it's good to know that
the web animations API can handle both
so let's try doing an animation next
using the shortcut method so here we
have two CSS animations happening on
Alice we have another animation
happening on the background but ignore
that we're most concerned with alice
alice is rotating all right okay cool I
get it you don't want to show with me so
alice is rotating but she's also
slightly fading changing her color so
she's rotating but she's also changed in
color this is what that CSS looks like
got Alice up here she's using the
animation Alice tumbling it's running
infinitely it takes three seconds for
each loop it's got a linear easing
function the keyframes specify at zero
percent her color is black and she has
no rotation at thirty percent her color
transforms to a kind of a burgundy and
then at one hundred percent it goes back
to black and her transform completes to
a 360 degree rotation just keep in mind
that thirty percent is important this is
how that shortcut I was talking about
looks you get the element call animate
on it you pass it keyframes and you pass
it timing options very familiar so this
is the keyframe object we could we could
pass it note that there's this offset
here so at zero percent this key we've
got the rotate zero of the color of
black butt down here on on the second
one we have to specify this offset of 0
point three the fun thing is if I didn't
if I didn't specify point three the web
animations API is so clever that it
would just take these keys and split
them up to happen at equidistant points
on the timeline so her color we changed
at fifty percent don't like fifty
percent specify you want
happen at pool you know thirty percent
point three it can take a what is it 1 /
3 2 it can take math it's JavaScript its
ass is a lot of fun because you can get
into some dynamic timing things there
now for the timing object I made this
Alice timing variable and you'll notice
that I have specified the duration in
milliseconds unlike CSS it does not take
seconds value like the rest of
JavaScript everything is milliseconds if
you're not using milliseconds in your
CSS you may want to start using them as
it will make parsing into web animations
API in the future a little bit easier if
you think you might be using it for
iterations we use the JavaScript keyword
infinity for a while I kept trying to
write infinite with quotes it wasn't
working then I remembered oh yeah that's
a keyword just use a capital I all right
so let's put them together we take
element animate and we turned it into we
get we go out we get Alice
document.getelementbyid e Alice animate
we pass it the Alice tumbling keyframes
and the Alice timing timing properties
object and boom look at that it's
exactly the same as the CSS version
exactly the same pretty cool we can do
better timelines and callbacks surely
you didn't come here to just see how to
do really long ways to do CSS animations
that's right animation the web
animations API does give us some pretty
cool new attributes and things that we
can do with them for instance we've got
unfinish which is a promise if you love
promises got on cancel if you also love
if you love promises and you want them
to run when the animation is canceled
there's the ready promise which tells
when your animation is ready to start
running and there's play state which
lets you know it's read-only you use
methods to call it it'll tell you
whether your animation is paused running
or reversing playback rate we'll talk
more about that later and there's effect
effect is handy because it points right
back to the keyframe effect if you ever
need to access it in the future
one day we might have different kinds of
effects we might have groups and
sequences so it's important to remember
this there are a couple of other cool
cool attributes like current time which
shows you your location on a timeline
and finished which is a call back and
we're going to use those so there's a
famous scene where alice is drinking and
eating and she's growing bigger and
smaller and I wanted to recreate that
with this particular experiment I wanted
to show Alice eating cake and getting
bigger or drinking a little glass of
water and getting smaller and I thought
surely this is a job for the web
animations API let's make a game with
that and this is what I had in mind so
basically you go over here and you're
toting down your mouse over the cake and
she gets bigger and when you hold down
the mouse over the soda she gets smaller
that's a lot of fun so how this is
housed how does this happening Alice
isn't on particular she is on a time
line going from big to small she starts
her the beginning of her animation is
really small and the end is really big
these are the two key poses that are in
for keyframe effect now clicking or
tapping on the different these two
things plays her forward or backwards so
they're actually kind of like fast
forward and rewind buttons for the
animation so first things first we go we
make an Alice change variable we get
Alice we slap her key frames and her
timing objects on there and then we hit
pause because when you use the animate
method it'll try to run immediately
so this is what happens when you do that
and you don't hit pause notice how she
went from really small to really big
we're going to just go ahead and put
pause on there and I'm officially at
time I apologize but I'm going to be
running a little bit over it's cool
you'll you'll be happy anyway alright so
let's set the let's set that duration we
want to make sure that she starts in the
middle because that looks weird seeing
her explode like that we want to make
sure that when we start playing the game
she is about halfway between those two
so we do that by grabbing her duration
we say Ellis we say Ellis change we want
to set your current time to using her
effect which points back to her keyframe
effect we inspect her timing object and
we grab her duration and then we divide
it by two so we're setting her playhead
her current time to be halfway through
now we're going to tie it back to those
playback controls so we've got the
timeline and we want to set the playhead
right there now we need to control the
playhead on that timeline sending it
forward and backward we use the cake and
bottle to send it forward and backward
and we're going to see how we do that we
know forwards so let's start with back
we're going to create a shrink Alice
function and we're going to set her
playback rate to negative one fun thing
about playback raids if you pass
negative values to them they run
backwards so you could do a negative 2
and she'd run backwards twice as fast
fun and what happens is we're going to
hit play and then we're going to also
play the animation on the on the bottle
as well and we attach that to an event
listener for four onmousedown we could
also use the reverse method just to
point this out the reverse method is
essentially a shortcut for setting the
playback rate to negative 1 and hitting
play all right let's see how that looks
oh it works perfectly now she gets
smaller wonderful so we do the same for
the cake the only difference is with the
cake we make sure to set the playback
rate to one we need a new way to stop
the animations now right so we create a
stop playing Alice function we make sure
to create we make little pauses for each
of the animations not just for Alice but
also for the cake in the drinking so
that the animations don't just keep
running long after you've stopped stop
clicking or tapping on the controls and
of course you attach them both to the
event listeners for Mouse up now we've
got these animations that go forward and
backwards but all good games have to
have endings there have to be outcomes
concrete outcomes right in a story Alice
wants to get through this tiny door so
that she can follow the white rabbit so
she eats a cake and she it's huge but
she's too big to go through the door so
she throws a tantrum and she cries and
there's this lake and their animals
stuck in it and it's really surreal but
the point is she cries a lot and she
gets really big so then she manages to
drink from the bottle to get small and
ends up swimming around in a puddle of
her own tears but the problem is that
she is so small that she forgot the key
she forgets the key off on the table and
she still can't get through the door
it's a tough life for Alice so I made
little vignettes of each of these scenes
me if she is too small by the time you
run out of animations by the time you
run out of either things to drink her
things to eat if she's too small you get
the two small ending if she's too big
you get the two big ending notice how
the pool of Tears is slowly growing
larger eventually it will engulf the
whole page so how do we tie that to our
controls well a good thing we're working
with timelines because now we've got two
timelines for both the animations on the
cupcake and the animation on the glass
of water so what we have to do is we
need to listen to when those animations
finish when either of these run out
we're going to get one of those
vignettes based on how big or how small
she is
that is to say how far along in her
animation she is too big let's play
again oh no it's going out like a candle
and of course you can make her grow a
little bits bigger or smaller this is
basically at the very end function will
fire to compare her current animations
playhead with her overall timeline
here's how we do that we need to set the
animations on finished call back we
basically say when the cake or the or
the water runs out we're going to run
end game or if Alice reaches the end of
her animation will also run end game for
some reason you manage to do that so
with end game we figure out her height
we're going to do that by taking her
playhead we find Alice's playhead by
asking what her current time is and then
we find out her timeline which is how
long her active duration lasts and we
divide them we divide her playhead by
the and the timeline figure out what
percentage of her animation is finished
we use an if-else statement to compare
how big she is if she is greater than
point if she's greater than thirty three
percent of her way through sorry less
than thirty three percent of the way
through she got smaller if she's bigger
than sixty seven percent of her way
through she got bigger anything in
between those values you just get a kind
of play again screen so we make sure
that we stop alamy her animation after
the end of the game and we combine all
of this since that endgame function so
small bonus other things that are really
hard to do with CSS animation
randomization and I know you can
randomize with with sass but what if you
want to randomize for each new user on
your site you don't want to run sass
every time someone visits so these tears
are completely randomized I did that by
taking this randomization function and
then passing it to her delay and her
duration to make sure that they would
fall within a special range it looks
really good and now here's another thing
you can only do
with the web animations API you can
adjust playback rate i'm super excited
about this because there are no CSS
variables or randomization spec that can
compare to this there's another great
scene from through the looking glass
when the stock stock people love this
she meets the red queen and in looking
glass land you have to run just to stay
in place and you have to run twice as
forward to move forward so what does
that look like in CSS well what does it
look like with the web animations API I
decided that Alice tires easily so
she'll slow down with time you'll notice
that she's running a little bit slower
there's a decay on there run cycle and
it's all down to that playback property
in the timing option the playback rate
property we've got the red queen we've
got there sprite animation but in here
we set the playback rate to one and
we're going to use a set interval every
three seconds we multiply that playback
rate by point nine so it's getting slow
we also cap it at so it never falls
below point for it gets really weird
trying to boost her out of that to speed
her up we use the same trick only we
register it clicking or tapping anywhere
and we multiply the playback rate by 1.1
so whenever you click or tap anywhere on
the page she goes faster and here are
our touch event listener as well and
this is what it looks like so watch what
happens we're going to tap tap tap tap
tap make her run faster well she's
slowing down because we're not there you
notice that the world starts sliding
backwards if she goes too slowly i'm
using playback rates on the other
objects too and if we tap really fast
come on you can do it you can do it you
can run ah poor little girl there we go
now they're finally getting somewhere
okay so the good news is that you can
start learning and using the web
animations API today in fact I recommend
you do so because these features are
starting to ship in Firefox and Chrome
there is a polyfill which all these
demos used it it does have a bug tracker
on github you are encouraged file bugs
it is maintained by people
from chrome and of course with input
from firefox it's wonderful it's pretty
performant and it does let you use these
things today even for browsers that are
being a little slower about implementing
it Edge has moved the API into their
to-do list and Safari has as well after
much feet dragging Thank You cannon okay
so the fun thing is that animation
libraries that you're using today gsm
ojs snap SVG they could build on top of
the web animations api to realize some
of these performance boosts that the api
provides by working directly with the
browser's animation engine there's no
need for raf requestanimationframe
there's no need for hacks for speed the
idea is that browsers can optimize the
animations in their engines and then you
can gain the benefits of those
optimizations by working directly with
the engine it also gives us a format to
export to for other tools to interface
with in the future as well and of course
more implementations means even better
tools this is Chrome's timelines which I
wanted to show how chrome has been using
this API to build their own animation
tools as well I would love to see more
browsers competing to make these things
keep an eye out for web animations API
level two which introduces grouping and
sequencing which will change everything
dan wilson creek wrote a great post
about it which the link is on the side
there you should check it out but it's
still a little ways off in the end all
animation is all animation is is time
and change and that's what this API
describes in doing so it makes way for
future animation specs ones we haven't
even thought of yet and the future of
animation online before i head out i
would like to thank some people who
helped me do this alex miller is a local
cartoonist in portland oregon who helped
me do the backgrounds for these when i
was very sick with pneumonia opalescence
did the logo chris mills was my sort of
mentor when writing the mdn
documentation and the n is your number
one source for all web animation api
docs i highly recommend it and brian
Birtles who wrote most of the spec and
has answered all of my questions he's a
great /
Santa hassle when you have questions
about the API so where can you learn
more about this well you can find this
into all links about it at rachel
neighbors calm /w AAP I web animations
API you can subscribe to the newsletter
web animation weekly calm as new things
happen it gets announced there and
lastly if you want to talk about the web
animations API we've got our own hashtag
on the animation at work slack channel
you can even talk to Brian bertles and
other people working directly with the
API there it's a good bunch of people
thank you for having us thank you for
letting me talk to you about the API
today
[Applause]